عندما كان بيني يبلغ من العمر 5 أشهر ونصف الشهر تقريبًا،
كان في سريره ولاحظت أن
إحدى عينيه كانت متوهجة وعندما لم أكن كذلك،
واعتقدت أنك تعرف أن هذا أمر مخيف لكنني
لم أفكر كثيرًا في الأمر
بعد ذلك  حدث ذلك مرة أخرى في
الليلة التالية، لذلك عرفت حينها أن هناك شيئًا
خاطئًا حقًا، حيث قام طبيب عيون للأطفال
بتشخيص إصابة بيني بورم أرومي في شبكية العين أو
سرطان يبدأ في شبكية العين في
نفس العين التي بدت سوداء على
جهاز مراقبة الطفل، وأعتقد أنني كنت أعرف أنه كان
سرطانًا  لكنني كنت آمل ألا يكون الأمر
مثل أي والد، حيث دخلت
الغرفة ووسعت عينيه ثم
قالت إنه كان أعمى من هذا الجانب وأن
هناك كتلة أنه
سرطان ونظرت إليها للتو وأنا
قالت هل سيرى مرة أخرى
ونظرت إلي وأتذكر فقط تلك
النظرة التي تشبه الألم في عينيها
وقالت إن هذا أقل ما يقلقك،
كل ما كنت أفكر في طرحه في تلك المرحلة
هو هل سيعيش الأطباء الذين حقنوا
العلاج الكيميائي مباشرة في  الورم
الذي يقول المستشفى إنه أقل توغلاً
من العلاج الكيميائي العادي وأنقذ
عين بيني، لا أعتقد أنني
كنت مستعدًا عاطفيًا لرؤيته بهذه الطريقة وهو
مربوط بهذه اللوحة وكانت لديه أسلاك
في كل مكان، لقد بدا صغيرًا جدًا
وبريئًا.  لقد كسر قلبي واستيقظ
وابتسم ثم عاد
للنوم، وكان لا يزال يستجمع طاقته
ليطمئننا جميعًا أنه
بخير الآن، ويبلغ من العمر 18 شهرًا،
ويتعافى بيني ويتلقى الرعاية في
مستشفى إنتر ماونتن الأساسي للأطفال في ولاية
يوتا.  أخبره أنه شجاع، إنه
قوي، إنه
يقاتل